you get this amazing part could you tell
your friends I'm in the next dead plum I
couldn't but I did know I could trust
him though yeah so you it's a small
country so everyone knows everyone's
right yeah so you were told explicitly
don't tell me when you're in Deadpool
and the first thing you did was tell
everybody new deal no no no no not no no
I told some people yeah okay yeah all
right and were they excited no they were
really excited but I told them too I
thought I made sure not to tell anyone
cuz they will die yeah yeah were you a
Ryan Reynolds like the ends with your
that's only in the movies yeah okay and
not in real life you can't really make
fire
that's the least scary thing my hands
are small dogs are scarier when you do
it it's scarier well first of all okay
let's talk about it your power your
super power in the movie is to shoot
fire out of your hands you're doing that
on the set that's got a feel kite was
super stupid like I was doing that and
nothing's happening because they add all
that stuff later yeah and I'd like dots
on my hand in everything I looked a
really stupid but I would David Lee
toric dad go over to the monitor and
look at the monitor and it'll be like
how does it look and I'm like doing all
of the staff and I'm yeah it was it
looked really stupid but it's you're not
good
yeah they add it later on but it's a lot
of trust yeah it released the movie and
if it was just you going yeah you'd have
been laughed out of school you know so
I'm glad it worked out for you even
before the movie also left us were you a
big Ryan Reynolds fan before you like I
like I saw his movies I wouldn't say I
was a fan you know like there was Green
Lantern Green Lantern was a really great
movie it was you're not gonna be in
Deadpool 3 you're screwing up big-time
here this guy you're Greenland is a
super nice guy he's a very nice guy
probably watch this so he's a super nice
guy really cool to work with amazing
family yeah he's just super nice yeah
that's because he's gonna watch this
yeah yeah we're leaving in the part
about Green Lantern though so you're
through
you